let me let let's just just talk about
the uh security issue real quick as kind
of the introduction so
i don't want to give specific details on
why or what's happening
um as many of you know i think out of
all of the shows in politics we may be
the most swatted of 2022 yeah six six so
far it's crossed state lines the latest
incident that we're dealing with now uh
the bomb squad
ah
surprise to me i go outside and i see a
bunch of vehicles pulling up and then i
see a guy get out he's got to share this
bomb squad on it and i was like oh the
bombsquad's at my house
and uh
you know i can't say exactly what
happened but it's effectively a swatting
not the exact same thing
and uh
man i got to be careful about some of
the details there's a lot to say but
maybe i can't actually say it there's
concerns obviously when we talk about
these security issues pertaining to
swattings or otherwise
that if we
highlight it it encourages it and we've
had police tell us that before and i'm
like you're right you know and so some
of these instances we've we've not
really talked about that much the other
concern is that
making sure people are aware of what's
going on is is important for the safety
and security
a similar sense i would hate to have
something happen
that would be unbelievable confusing or
just over i don't know how to
exactly explain it my concern was
you know if something keeps happening
and we ignore it and people don't know
what's happening and then something
serious happens it'll take everyone by
surprise maybe we should be like hey put
a put attack in this something's
happening we're having security issues
people should know what's happening but
most importantly you know before the
show we're trying to figure out how to
title what was going on and talk about
what's going on i was just like i said
this a moment ago if this was any other
outlet if it was crowder if it was the
daily wire if it was the new york times
we would be talking about it for a half
an hour we'd be we'd be exploring who
did it and we can't even get a lot of
those core details so
other than that i just you know
when we were trying to figure out what
our lead story was
usually we're up in the studio we're
sitting here we're talking this time
we're out in front with a bunch of cops
and i'm assuming feds and stuff like
that and so we didn't have the same kind
of ease of prep work and understanding
we normally get to do and so we're
trying to figure out you know do we do
we lead with this story oh no no we we
put one up those like joe biden sucks
and we were like he does and we want to
talk about those things but then it was
just like it's an opinion statement and
it's just like well we have the story
from from james o'keefe but he didn't
actually upload the video yet and i'm
like oh did i just accidentally you know
break his story before him so i'm like
we got to change it i'm like you know
the bomb squad's here yeah yeah i can't
deal with this i thought it's like the
balance of as a
weird internet celebrity whatever you
call this weird new genre of like you're
a creator your personality is your
character
you got to balance out your own mental
health with the journalistic integrity
of documenting your life so that people
know in the future like what you went
through and so they know what to expect
if they're gonna try and reproduce what
you're doing
sometimes talking about the bad things
that happen to you is bad for your
mental health and you have to just
let it fly let it go
as we talk about you know the conflict
in this country and the culture war and
stuff i'm also kind of concerned that we
would omit relevant news in this space
because it's happening to us right i
don't know if you guys what your
thoughts are on that because because
there's the self-interest thing where
we've had the cop be like
don't tell anyone this happened because
it'll make it worse and i'm like yeah
but if there's a new york times
journalist outside filming all of this
they'd post that online in two seconds
and tell everybody what was happening
regardless of our security or otherwise
and it would be a major topic of
conversation about the escalation and
what's happening with these political
conversations with censorship with
violence and things like that
yeah no it's a tough call i
can't tell you one way or the other i
think that you have total control over
the information here at least with
respect to whether it gets out i mean we
don't really have anyone else from the
new york times filming this obviously
things can get out either way just
because of people telling their family
members about what's happening things
along those lines but
yeah i'm not sure man it it is a tough
call i think it makes sense on some
level it makes sense to talk about it
just because people should know
the danger that is present in discussing
these issues publicly or how psychotic
people have become and how psychotic
people have become as well and i think
they should also know that having any
kind of public political platform does
come at a cost and i'm not saying that
so that people can be
you know more careful and and more
afraid to speak out about their values
when they need to it's actually the
exact opposite to embolden them and have
them say these maniacs cannot intimidate
us
into silence yeah especially when
there's lots of people doing it together
when people start speaking out together
it's like you can't whack all the moles
at once you just give up at that point
the moles on the garden look you've done
a bunch of stories that have really
riled a lot of people up i'm curious if
you've dealt with similar stuff or if
you have thoughts on
you know i think there's a lot of
keyboard warriors online that want to
intimidate and there's a lot of people
and this is not what you're doing what
happened to you is serious it's happened
a number of times a lot of journalists
want to play a victim you know someone i
got a death threat and it's like some
guy like sent you a dm on twitter that's
like you know like i wish you were dead
like all right that's not a credible
threat right um but when you look at
what's happened with january 6 there's
been like all these long magazine
articles like the journalists are having
to go to therapy and i think what you've
dealt with is objectively probably more
serious than those journalists that were
there for essentially a riot so
that's a good point and it's a big
component of like what
how i'm feeling when they're saying like
don't tell people this is happening and
i'm like
we just said that story from project
veritas i don't know if you guys saw it
where that the journalist was like you
were not traumatized by january 6. you
know did you see this video where he's
basically saying like you are out there
having fun you are not worried
and they the dem the the uh the democrat
narrative on january 6 is like the
violent insurrection the journalists
narrative on everything they do is like
every day i wake up and someone sends me
mean words yeah and then it's like
we actually have
we were swatted six times now we've had
an incident where the bomb squad's been
deployed and you know i don't wanna i
can't go into details but there there is
a reason for why they're deployed it
wasn't um it wasn't the same as a
swatting like something actually
happened we have to be careful about
discussing the full details but uh
it caught it cause
whatever happened was serious enough
where they actually called
reinforcements so like
i'm actually worried we're going to hear
you know the house shake or something
like that yeah like there may actually
be something about to happen
there's no but well i'm asking people
pray i mean if you pray the rosary pray
the rosary but just prayer in general be
very very appreciative there's not
really an instruction manual for this
kind of career path so i think this is
just par for the course probably just a
matter of having a precaution set up
like perimeters set up where things get
looked at and inspected on their way in
so that we don't come to a point where
security security is insane well
we're getting crazy with it i'll also
say this i i definitely understand the
argument that it could be dangerous to
speak out about this to some extent
because then you incentivize copycat
criminals or you embolden the person
who's doing it in the first place but as
you've mentioned we are living in an era
of crocodile tears and i think it's
important for people to see people who
actually are put in a situation of
danger not falling apart and losing it
because they want to score cheap
political points with their hysteria
well i'm just you know
shouldn't
the new york times have talked about any
one of these major instances where we
got swatted like live on air what's up
for them
right right and so what i kind of see
here is you'll hear the narrative from
the corporate journalists about how
they're so oppressed
but they obviously have disdain for us
they don't care about us you know that
what happens to us is not news to these
big corporate entities but whatever
happens to them is yeah i mean you're a
journalist who's literally being
attacked as are the people around you as
is james o'keefe as is james o'keefe and
so you know it's it's funny how if you
are outside the establishment it's clear
there's there's two there's two uh
different worlds here those who are
actually resisting those who are
actually standing up for the individual
or for rights uh and those who are
shills for corporations those who are
shills for themselves are grifting you
know do you think there are elite people
that are elite that are actually trying
to help the individuals and not shilling
for corporations or so you can be elite
and not be a shell bro i mean like we're
a big company we make a lot of money you
know what i mean like i was asking
shameless
he was like elite are the people that
will never get in trouble for what they
did
that's a horrible way of
spaying the truth to me shane thanks um
but can those people that never get in
trouble be good people too that's what
i'm wondering like or are they just kind
of ousted like elon musk he's definitely
wealthy enough to be in that group but
is he accepted in that group because
he's not a sociopath at least doesn't
seem to be that's an interesting
question i mean they say absolute power
can corrupt absolutely so it's difficult
to find people in that kind of a
position who have the integrity to
behave decently but i'm sure there are
some
that's promising
yeah there's look you can look at donald
trump and especially with what's been
going on uh earlier today i'm looking at
all the news and i'm like thinking like
man what is the lead story you got
you've got russia sanctioning hillary
clinton and joe biden and hunter biden
and i'm like that's that's interesting
but does it really matter is it you know
then you've got some crazed you know
some angry i should say chris but some
angry tv host in russia saying someone
should tell the us you give us back our
money or you get the tactical or
strategic your choice which is in
reference to nuclear strike against us
and then i'm like but he's just some guy
in tv i mean he doesn't really there's
some guy's waving his arms and then i'm
just like
and then i i saw someone tweeted about
trevor noah uh ian miles chong tweeted
about trevor no because uh he was saying
it makes no sense doing the vax mandates
in new york now because kyrie irving
couldn't play but he could go and hug
the players as a fan it's the craziest
thing ever and then i just thought to
myself like man joe biden really is like
the worst president we've ever had isn't
he and then i'm like well woodrow wilson
yes he's bad too though yeah we were
talking about this before the show and
it's a complicated question because even
though i really didn't like obama or
clinton i definitely didn't think w was
the best if someone asked me who's the
worst president i probably would have
pointed to woodrow wilson but there is
something about having a person in the
oval office who literally cannot speak
that makes me reconsider that position
or want to reconsider that position
biden could be the worst president we've
ever had and i don't say that for sure
being a bad president can take different
ways you could be a like a private
associate like a psychopath that's like
uses the law to bend to his will that's
a horrible president but then you get
the demented human that can't function
properly that doesn't speak that's a bad
a word i mean in my opinion that's more
dangerous i'd rather have a an
authoritarian psychopath that at least
is gonna help the country function uh
mechanically this guy is like
embarrassing us
when he speaks that's a good point
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you